pourquoi les ours polaires n'ont ils pas
froid c'est vrai qu'il ne faut pas être
frileux quand on habite sur la banquise
de l'océan arctique
heureusement pour lui l'ours polaire est
particulièrement adapté à son
environnement
d'abord il possède une fourrure très
épaisse ensuite sa peau sous cet épais
manteau et noir ce qui lui permet de
mieux capter la chaleur du soleil il
dispose également d'une couche de
graisse pouvant atteindre 10 cm
d'épaisseur et qui constitue un
formidable isolant par rapport aux
autres espèces d'ours il a aussi
quelques particularités qui l'aident à
résister au froid ça que plus courte et
ses oreilles plus petit lui évite par
exemple de perdre trop de chaleur tandis
que son museau sensiblement plus l'aude
lui permet de davantage réchauffer l'air
avant qu'il n'arrive jusqu'à ses poumons
avec tout ça même lorsque la température
descend jusqu'à -40 degrés en hiver eh
bien il n'a aucun mal à rester fort
comme annonce